ja und es waren mal elf freunde in der
vorletzten woche zum start des
fünfzehnten dschungelcamps in südafrika
und jetzt sind es immer weniger geworden
bereits hochkant rausgeflogen janina
josef jantar anbieter und jasmin herren
also sind jetzt noch acht camper übrig
gestern dann die premiere peter althoff
und eric steht fest werden denn eine
dschungelprüfung gewählt eric verweigert
aber ja er will keine sterne für leute
erspielen die nur hinter seinem rücken
über ihn lästern aha wir schauen uns die
situation nochmal genauer an
ich bin motiviert meine sache dort zu zu
machen die ich dich zu machen so gut wie
ich möchte dir zu dieser
dschungelprüfung antreten
ich bin ein star holt mich hier raus
ich habe tatsächlich keine angst nur ist
es so dass es im camp menschen gibt die
ganz frei heraus sagen dass ziemlich
richtig scheiße finden meine
persönlichkeit scheiße finden und meine
gefühle benutzt haben um mir
irgendwelche geschichten zu erzählen und
deshalb bin ich nicht bereit für
menschen essen zu erspielen die mich
nicht leiden können das mache ich esse
seit vielen prüfungen schon nicht mehr
mit
cinryze und trinkwasser das reicht mir
weil ich eben genau das nicht will
möchte nicht in der bringschuld kommen
für menschen die mir nicht gut tun und
die mich nicht mögen
und hallo haben die prüfungen nicht
gemacht
aus dem grund weil es hier menschen gibt
die zum einen ganz offen sagen dass sie
mich scheiße finden
und zum anderen dass es hier menschen
gibt die meine gefühle ausgenutzt haben
indem sie mir irgendwelche fake
geschichten erzählen ich weiß auch noch
nicht ganz genau ob ich mich weiterhin
bereit erkläre mich an die regeln zu
halten weil ich es auch nicht möchte
dass diese menschen ihre
luxusgegenstände behalten warum auch und
ich bin auch nicht bereit für alle hier
waren es waren platz zu schaffen die
irgendwelche scheiße erzählen hier eine
sache noch blockweise ich hierbleibe
rate ich euch wenn ihr essen wollte mich
nicht in die prüfung zu schicken weil
sonst geht so weiter
ja was ist da los das wollen wir wissen
von bild live show chefin janina kirsch
denn sie hat den bild buschfunk
[Musik]
alle für einen einer für alle das würde
man meinen aber nicht im dschungelcamp
und vor allem nicht mit eric steht es
denn der spielt einer gegen alle er
sprengt das dschungelcamp und genau
darüber müssen wir jetzt sprechen heute
an meiner seite
publikumsliebling und junge star peter
orloff ich freue mich ganz herzlich dass
du hier bist peter wir haben die szene
gerade schon gesehen eric verweigert die
prüfung und lässt die kandidaten somit
hungern was hast du gedacht also das
gestern abend gewinner ist also erst mal
ich freue mich total dass ich hier heute
war ich bin und ja ich war schon sehr
sehr beeindruckt dass da wirklich eine
ansage kam die für mich eigentlich ein
absolutes no go ist denn man ist ja in
einer schicksalsgemeinschaft man ist
zwar konkurrent aber man ist natürlich
auch verantwortlich dafür dass alle ihr
futter bekommen abends und
das also einmalig zu durchbrechen wie er
das gemacht hat das ist natürlich
erfordert natürlich auch schon eine
gewisse
ja da muss man auch schon bald
dazukommen er hat ja da wird sogar
riskiert aus der sendung zu fliegen weil
und es war ja auch alles geplant denn es
war geborgen war es ein ganz perfider
plan er tage lang nichts gegessen von
dem erspielten sondern nur reis und
bohnen damit er nicht in eine art
bringschuld kommt damit die kandidaten
nicht sagen können wir haben doch auch
für dich geschrieben du hast doch auch
das essen gegessen was wir gespielt
haben und in meinen augen ist das eine
kriegserklärung an die kandidaten er
spielte nicht da er wusste über sie und
lasst sie hunger vor allem er hat ja
wirklich wie du richtig sagt ja dass ihr
verlange hand vorbereitet er hat sich
auch noch von denen die er dann
anschließend sanktioniert hat wählen
lassen in die prüfung und das bedeutet
natürlich als auch angekündigt da
passiert was aber dass das passiert
natürlich keiner gedacht und ich denke
mal er hat jetzt freut uns halt bestraft
aber wer bis dahin vielleicht noch für
ihn war wird jetzt neu für ihn sein und
jetzt ist er natürlich ganz allein einer
gegen alle und voll was eine alle für
einen einer für alle und das hat er
genau konterkariert und hat praktisch
sich selbst gegen alle positioniert das
ist hat am ersten tag noch keine folgen
gebracht weil die beiden drama queens
auf der abschussliste standen
glücklicherweise für die beiden ist es
eben nicht dazu gekommen aber ich habe
viel konnten die nix dieser eine von den
beiden hat normalerweise camp verlassen
du redest von jena und anderen länder
und anuschka die vielleicht mittel
verwechseln die em bewerbung die stehen
nicht auf der gästeliste stehen auf der
speisekarte
und
speisekarten lass uns noch einmal über
diesen aspekt hunger reederei das ist ja
das einzige das essen ist das einzige
worauf sich die kandidaten irgendwie ja
auch freuen ideen in die
dschungelprüfung um etwas zu essen zu
bekommen
es gibt wenig womit sie sich
beschäftigen können das heißt das ist
auch so ein highlight was bedeutet das
wenn jetzt auch jemand sagt werd mich
mich in die prüfung weil dann werdet ihr
die nächsten tage nicht zu essen
bekommen was macht das mit rein ja ich
denke mal jetzt hat er natürlich die
divas gefallen lassen und jetzt weiß man
bei ihm er ist gegen alle und er ist
nicht bereit sich in die gemeinschaft zu
integrieren
das ist eine sehr frühe kriegserklärung
an alle und trifft womöglich auch den
einen oder anderen denn gar nichts getan
hat dass man im dschungel natürlich
nicht in betreutes wohnen geht das ist
klar und dass man auf der anderen seite
natürlich trotzdem wahrhaftig sein
sollte authentisch das ist die andere
seite denn das publikum kann sehr sehr
gut erkennen und werten die jemand ist
wie authentisch hältst du das wenn er
hat ja allen anderen vorgeworfen sie
sind fake sie jetzt machen nur eine
große show da hab ich gestern so gedacht
na ja also aber was denkst du endlich wo
du dahin gegangen bist weil das ist ein
unterhaltungsformat da muss man schon
machen und b habe ich gedacht lieber
eric was tust du da eigentlich gerade
weil das war für mich mehr als
inszeniert und mehr als show hast du das
gesehen ja genauso also es war
tatsächlich lange vorbereitete man muss
ja mehrere tage vorher es schon die
entscheidung getroffen haben und dabei
die karten werden erst mal gemischt in
der ersten woche und
natürlich denkt man mit dem einen oder
anderen an ich habe gesungen als ich da
drin vario mit machtmensch der dschungel
ist eigentlich draußen das ist doch
eigentlich alles ganz toll und worüber
reden wir hier aber man kann natürlich
auch konfrontation suchen um sich zu
profilieren und
das ist vielleicht manchmal auch der
fall also ich sage mal das niveau auch
des verbalen geht manchmal ein bisschen
unter gehört liegen aber gut das gehört
dazu manchmal manchmal ist es eben auch
dann über alle grenzen das ist zum teil
der ersten woche haben wir das ja
gesehen und man muss wirklich auch sehen
dass man trotz allem nie diese stil
bewahrt denn
irgendwo ist das spiegelbild der
gesellschaft die ganze sendung ist ja
eine eine wahnsinnig interessante
sendung und was da
abgelaufen ist auch an provokationen an
anderen an mobbing und natürlich auch an
logos das ist schon das hat schon eine
eine eine qualität die es vorher nicht
gab eine negative qualität und deswegen
das hat jetzt wieder eine neue dimension
noch geschaffen und natürlich sind
dadurch die karten wirklich neu gemischt
ordentlich kann wir verraten dass die
twitter gemeinde auch wieder ganz ganz
aktiv war und dieser eklat um elik steht
fest diese bombe die er gestern hat
platzen lassen hat natürlich auch im
netz für trasse diskussion gesorgt dass
best of twitter wollen wir uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam anschauen in unserem junge
rada
dschungel und es knallt nicht nur im
busche sondern auch auf twitter unter
dem hashtag liebes für ich bin ein star
bekommt für einen trick steht es den
hält der twitter gemeinde ab weil mehr
die prüfung verweigert die unsere top
five der fliesen direkt wies da denkt
man man hat in 15 staffeln schon alles
gesehen und dann kommt eric aus dem jahr
1311 und wird den ausschlag wahnsinn
zwar bekommen rx kollegen nichts zu
essen aber es hat auch was gutes
zumindest für manche wenn du einmal ganz
eric nicht mehr der unbeliebteste tempo
vola bist eric steele ist bekommt auch
von dieser twitter userin sein fett weg
eric die rc nur scheiße wir sind alle
fällt auch erics ich habe schon mal 1311
als ritter gelebt aja klettert auf der
abschussliste weiter nach oben zur
freude seiner mitbewohner ich bin eric
sicht komplett hinausschießt schade
stehe fest peter althof hätte gerne ein
paar sterne geholt aber hey wenn ihre
prüfung ab bricht aber du noch deinen
stein witz bringen konnte später das
schaffst du dich nur du
ja und für alle die den kleinen witz mit
1311 nicht verstanden haben ihr ex
stadtrat tatsächlich kürzlich im
dschungelcamp erzählt dass er schon
einmal gelebt hat und zwar im jahr 1311
weder du hast gerade schon gesagt es gab
viel negative energie auch in der
letzten woche ein ganz großes thema war
natürlich der rassismus skandal und
janina josef k wir haben am freitag am
freitag gesagt sie hier genau auf diesem
platz war hier und hat uns das
allererste interview gegeben nach ihrem
rauswurf das war
emotional
das war auch traurig das war in erster
linie aber sehr ehrlich und da möchten
wir jetzt noch einmal gemeinsam
reinschauen
für mich
selig total kaputt und
ich fühle mich einfach ob ich einen
falschen film wäre linda wenn du raus
bis aus dem dschungelcamp bitten in
meine entschuldigung an und du weißt
ganz genau es war wirklich nicht
rassistisch gemeint und ich habe es
keine sekunde so rassistisch gemeint ich
bin selber ausländerin und ich habe die
erfahrung ich selber am eigenen leibe
gemacht
rassistisch attackiert zu werden
war selber opfer und glaubst du ich hab
dir das auch gesagt bei der
entschuldigung glaubst du ich bin ich
bin ein rassist ich hab dich noch
gefragt ich hab dich noch darum gebeten
dass du nicht verstehst du ich hoffe
dass du einfach jetzt meine
entschuldigung bitte annimmst bitte
bitte linde ich habe mich noch nicht mal
getraut meine eigene mutter anzurufen
wieso nicht
welcher kirche immer ich hätte die
irgendwie abgestimmten den scheiß nazi
und
ich bin rassist ich hab' ich habe das
überhaupt nicht so gemeint und es gibt
ja auch sehr leid meine klar kann ich
das nicht mehr rückgängig machen aber im
selben moment kann niemand meine mami
erklären was da passiert ist
wir haben wir wollen jetzt noch einmal
mit janina josef jahren sprechen und ich
freue mich dass sie sich heute noch
einmal hier in unsere sendung dazu
schaltet die wird janina es war ein sehr
emotionaler tag am freitag jetzt in so
zwei tage vergangen das wochenende ist
vorbei mich würde interessieren wie
waren die reaktionen auf das interview
und auf deine öffentliche entschuldigung
bei uns
die reaktion ein sehr gutes
verständnis
für mich und dafür
dass
dafür dass wenn man die enge getrieben
wird dass man fehler macht ja
weniger verständnis für die
verantwortlichen für ihre rasche
entscheidung und den ausschluss von mir
also ich wollte mich auch nochmal für
die der liebe nachrichten und e mails
noch mal bei allen ich doch mal bedanken
das gibt mir natürlich auch bis in kraft
du hast am freitag erzählt dass du dich
nicht getraut hast deine mutter
anzurufen du bist dann in tränen
ausgebrochen
der grund dafür ist dass du dich einfach
geschämt hass und auch nicht wusstest
videos erklären soll es hast du
mittlerweile eine reaktion von deiner
familie wir bekommen konntest du mit
deiner mama sprechen
ja so
meine schwester hat mich natürlich
versucht anzurufen
nachdem sie das auch bei bild gesehen
hat sie wollte mir nur sagen dass meine
familie hinter mir steht und ich hab nur
meine muttersprache nachricht geschickt
also verwurzelt
bin immer noch nicht so in der lage
weil ich einfach emotional
selig noch nicht in der lage bin mich
damit auseinander zu setzen und meine
familie hat auch bisher gut im bauch
wie ich behandelt worden bin sie
verstehen nicht wie kann man einen
menschen den man nicht kennt
die ganze zeit bleiben beschimpfen
und so in die enge treiben
darüber ist meine familie sehr guten und
hat überhaupt kein verständnis für die
verhaltensweise die länder in die tage
gelegt hat dass sie mich vom wort des
abends immer beleidigt hat und fragte
mich warum hat diese frau linda dich so
abgrundtief gehasst ich habe keine
erklärung dafür warum sie mich sogar
hass dass ich weiß es nicht und ich habe
versucht einmal auch irgendwie wie es
möglich war im dschungelcamp ihr aus dem
weg zu gehen was natürlich nicht einfach
ist wenn man in so einem engen raum
zusammen mit einer der haupt und
miteinander klar kommen muss ja jeder
ist schwierig ist ja
es ist ganz klar dass du auch von von
ländern eine enge getrieben wurde wir
haben es aber auch am freitag hier schon
gesprochen es ist natürlich trotzdem
keine entschuldigung für die worte die
da gefahren wie gesagt es ist keine
entschuldigung ich habe mich jetzt so
oft weil dinge heraus schuldig
eine frage denn noch so oft eine
frage abschließend weil wir ein bisschen
unter zeitdruck stehen würdest du
einfach mit ja oder nein beantworten
würdest du einer versöhnung mit linda
auf ein aufeinandertreffen mit länder
zustimmen
ich habe mich jetzt noch bei lena
entschuldigt und ich würde sie
gerne noch einmal treffen und paar
fragen ihr stellen warum sie mich immer
jeden tag beleidigt hat ob sie und dann
natürlich auch dass es
dass ich mich auch jetzt so mehrfach bei
ihr entschuldigt habe wie sie darüber
denkt und
wie lange hat sie eine erklärung warum
ziemlich so gehasst oder warum sie musst
du hast kannst du mir das erklären
janina vielleicht werdet wird es noch
dazu kommen wir sind auf jeden fall
gespannt ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei dir und ich wünsche dir für die
schönen und für die nächsten tage alles
gute halte durch peter letzte frage an
dich ganz kurz fest ein favorit wer wird
das ding nach hause fahren der wird
gewinnen ja ich denke mal der harald
glöckler ist sehr weit vorne hat aber
inzwischen konkurrenz bekommen vom
manuel erstaunlicherweise dir also der
sich erst entwickelt hat den letzten
tagen dass ich auch eine prüfung sehr
gut auch gezeigt hat
dann die tina macht auch einen ganz
guten job inzwischen präsentiert peter
althoff ist ohne die kenne ich von
vielen veranstaltung also ein ganz
lieber kerl und er tut ja auch keinem
weh also der denn er könnte jedem video
und tut's nicht also insofern ich glaube
in der ersten woche sollte man nicht zu
früh schon die die die rollen wir haben
jetzt nur noch wenige tage du sagst ganz
vorne harald glöckler manuel und tina
wir sind gesprochen und peter althof das
muss er jetzt sagen war er heißt ja auch
peter
vielen dank peter wir werden sehen wie
es weitergeht sie bekommen auf jeden
fall alle infos zum dschungel jeden tag
hier im bild buschfunk und ich gebe
jetzt zurück an feli und lisa